hey guys to celebrate hitting 15,000
subscribers we have an amazing guest
here on the channel today
Rico Fajardo also known as the voice of
Miri oh how you doing man what just came
out 'la million showed up just the other
day and I've been getting so much love
online it's been crazy man
honestly it was so good you and Kevin
both like it was absolutely epic I was
just hanging out with kelan last night
we just did an escape room together
because he's in town recording for more
overhaul so yeah it's really great that
you know the heroes and villains can
hang out that there's you know there's a
place for us to all be together and be
chill yeah I wonder what an escape movie
with Mira and overhaul would actually be
like like the actual characters though
probably pretty easy cuz overall just
like take apart the walls and miR you
could just face the room be like oh yeah
the endings over here so that what you
actually just mentioned kind of ties it
into the first question so what I did I
have a bunch of questions from people
that they've been sending in and I have
just like a few questions that I wrote
that people didn't kind of cover and so
okay one of the questions that I've
always wanted to ask like a voice actor
essentially you know my hair academia's
almost at the halfway point now right
for this season right so my question to
you was when you guys are recording do
you record like a bunch of episodes in
bulk or do you do like one episode at a
time or how does it work so it's it's
pretty unique with my hero academia
because over at Funimation and this is
only in over the last you know a few
years Simon started we're you know we
will record the show shortly after the
Japanese recording the show and you know
we're on but usually there's about a few
weeks latency sometimes a bit more but
that was you know that the dubbing
process was a lot quicker than it was
before but now we are on simulcast which
is it's the materials the second we get
them we're working on them which is
really cool it has to do with technology
being a lot better nowadays and you know
our ability to sometimes record remotely
you know actors who because they always
see if the actors are all over the place
pretty pretty transient folk we are so
it's hard sometimes to get you know
everyone in the same studio so being
able to record remotely like for
instance with Kelvin in Los Angeles
every once in a while or like you know
if I take a trip to New York I can
record but yeah I would say that you
know typically it's not in bulk for my
hero it's actually pretty rare for that
ever to occur I think we had a hiatus
for a little bit where there were some
some episodes that got stored up a
little bit I guess you could say like
two or three we're kind of ready but for
the most part because it is simulcast we
are I mean the ink is like the
electronic ink is barely wet on the page
as we are beginning to record so yeah
right okay so does that mean like do you
know what happens for the rest of the
season or you're gonna kind of just like
take it one episode at a time
oh I mean okay so personally from actors
one of you I like to read everything
whenever I have a role that's pretty
substantial I like to you know do as
much research as I can so that's just
drama school it's like you want to you
want to bone up on all your knowledge
about the thing so for me I've read most
of the manga so I'm pretty caught up
actually so the series yeah and I you
know it's that's just how I roll
but um yeah in regards through the
animation though that's always a delight
because you never know you can see it in
the comic you know you can see it on a
panel and be like oh this is gonna be
awesome but then once you hear the music
and all the elements and all your other
friends acting across from you and you
know the animation obviously it's just
it it takes on a whole a whole new sort
of feeling so yeah yeah for sure man
awesome well let's get into the viewer
questions I'm gonna try and say
everyone's username but some of them are
like really weird okay that's great so
I'll try I will also try to say that so
the first question is from Tanner so he
says what sort of preparations if any
we're done for your audition and did you
specifically audition for me Rio or we
kind of like offered that role after
they heard your voice
so the audition process for when I ended
up booking me Rio I was on vacation
visiting some of my girlfriend's family
in Florida
or in Destin and I get an email from
Colleen saying hey you know can have an
important audition if you can get back
to me in a few days I have a couple
characters and want you to read for
essentially the the breakdown for the
for the characters because she didn't
want to reveal I think what the
characters were necessarily but she did
have you know some lines and so she gave
some background and more or less where
she wanted the voice to to be so
essentially for me it was my most heroic
sort of voice and then my most
villainous sort of voice and come to
find out you know sometime later that I
was auditioning for both miryo and
overhaul at the time which was really
exciting
so I after I auditioned and usually when
you do it on the fly so I was doing it
out of town I have a better microphone
at home like my home studio is kind of
tuned out for for most of my recording
but when I'm on the on the road it's
kind of actually what you're hearing
right now you know this is when I would
be there the quality of the audio which
is fortunately good right now but it's
nice and quiet you know planes flying
overhead no birds chirping but but yes I
did record you know a kind of slapdash
version for Colleen hero and villain
she asked for a follow-up she said you
know can you give me it gave me a couple
director notes like you know for the
hero can we make him a bit younger you
know more like high school age and you
know for the for the villain can we
really like dig into this like sort of
uh you know um what did she say effort
can't remember the note exactly but it
was almost like maniacal you know I
think was the note and I was like okay
and of course you know now that now that
we see the characters like I see where
you're headed with this but yeah after
that was after I sent those those in the
second check it around
Colleen responded pretty quickly and
said okay I'm pretty confident of you
know who you're gonna be playing if you
could do me a favor would you mind
reading some of some of these manga and
so you know she sent me some materials
and suggested summer which I went to the
bookstore and I bought because honestly
I this and hopefully this isn't this may
be answering someone's question in the
future but I wasn't like caught up on my
hero
as most of our fans know there's a lot
of content out there and so between like
right now I'm juggling like Witcher and
the expanse and like someone else just
recommend and another great show to me
I'm like there's so much good stuff to
see I'm gonna start today play the games
no see I downloaded the witcher 3
yesterday like me and my girlfriend
we're ready to do everything we're gonna
watch the show play the game so good i
love doing a charisma spec that's
essentially like a Jedi mind trick
people with a witcher power so it's yeah
you like it see seeds crowd control so
you like stun your opponent but anyway
sorry I guess I digress but yeah it's in
a nutshell that that was the auditioning
process for from me Rio for me anyways
and then once I got the Hmong against
our reading I recognized who who I was
playing and it all started to bloom in
front of me and my buddy Matt Shipman
he is eNOS uh and my hero academia he's
the tornado boy and also in dr. stone he
plays a chrome I play Ty's you and dr.
stone we were friends like so can we
play a lot of games together and do
stuff but he's like dude you know do you
know who Mario is and I was like I have
I don't really know him it cuz he was
like he was super caught up like he read
everything and he's like dude you gotta
understand this character is huge and
I'm like okay cool man you know like
that one step at a time I didn't
recognize the gravity of it all until
his excitement kind of then sparked my
excitement yep here we are today I
literally I can't pitch he being overall
like what would that have been like if
you dude you know it's funny I guess the
thing of it is like you know I've played
villains before I don't get to play them
too often I like to think that most
directors will cast you you know because
they can see a thing in you so I guess I
don't know if that's a compliment you
know for for I mean I think kalons did
an incredible job but there are times
where he's like man I he's so mean and
he like looks all sad and I'm like dude
but that's like you know they that
that's not everyone can do that man to
bring light back grit and that sort of
that killer instinct to things but then
again you know every villain of course
doesn't think they're a villain
you know most villains think they're
doing the right thing and they are in
fact the hero of their own stories yeah
I probably I don't know it's it's hard
it's hard to to count you know count
chickens that we'll never have because
it's but but uh I will say that I
probably had a lot of fun with it I mean
he definitely has such an interesting
thing going on with that plague doctor
mask
yeah and he's such an interesting
character I wonder and I mean I don't
want to do spoilers for anyone listening
through this but like I'm I'm curious of
the you know the the future of overhaul
oh yeah we can talk about another
podcast perhaps yes yeah I would love to
so moving on to the next question what
was that so this one's from roboticized
and they said how far do you stray from
your original voice to get the right
voice for the million oh god this is
such an easy question I apologize ahead
of time but it's because coleen coleen
for a casting she is notorious for
casting very well for my hero like
putting people in the pocket and there's
a kind of adel and the age-old adage
with theater I guess casting it enlarge
for directors that if you cast properly
you don't have to direct too hard you
know like your job is mostly done for
you if you find if the if the actor is
sort of in the pocket where they need to
be they don't mean to and don't get me
wrong you know we actors love to study
and learn dialect and you know do
research I mean that's that's half the
fun of the job is figuring out all the
nuts and bolts of it but it is
delightful I got to say for forum area
because it's essentially my voice just a
chipper caffeinated
I think version of myself that's like
just you know always always on the edge
of a smile which I typically am everyone
when I when I got this role is just
telling me it's just pretty much
human-like and it fits perfectly which
I'm very humbled because I think Mary is
like incredible carrot so I'm like oh my
god like when Colleen said that to me
she's like it's just you I like I
started getting weepy to like wait you
really think that of me like all this
guy's fantastic so yeah so just that
question it's pretty much as
just me what about what about that exact
same question but for the voice of
Mario's dad how did you like change it
for that well I guess yeah that the fun
part for that is uh I just had Kel him
the other night we are at dinner and he
was like do you know who voices Mario's
dad and I was like oh that's me man
and he was like wait what Holly yeah
like I was I thought he was joking
because he was like you know given you
know giving me some a hard time but he
was being genuine and I thought I was
like that's a really high compliment um
I my my big boy voice my kind of warrior
voice I've used a similar voice in her
up tales of Arslan where I played our
yoonhee's a Dark Knight and yeah at
first time I invented that voice was
inspired by my buddy Marcus stomach he's
kind of a lower baritone sort of voice
and barrel-chested bigger guy bearded
you know and we were doing we're working
on Romeo and Juliet at the time at Dow
at Shakespeare Dallas this is like 2016
and Marcus was playing
tibalt then I was playing Romeo and
every time we did our fight he would
have this sort of way he would speak and
it was very you know percussive and
strong and I remember thinking man
that's a cool voice and so you know like
you know good artists borrow great
artists steal and so he stole from Mark
is that I kind of like took this very
like deeps barrel-chested sound which
honestly I'd never really played with
very much and then I think I think Chris
Bevins was the first person to cast me
using this kind of tone and shall we
worked on and then like we did
danganronpa together but it really took
it really kind of blossomed this sort of
like more older voice in in our Celyn
yeah and yeah and really from there I
was like oh that's the sort of a warm
behind the heart sort of dad it's also
been called like my dad voice yeah it's
it's like you know got children behave
you know sort of things so um yeah I
would say for Mario's Mario's dad it
just you know dropped a little bit in
Tambor but mostly the warmth I like to
think of things of where they resonate
so like I said behind the heart I feel
like his Mario's dad's like supportive
parent like it's he's got to have like a
big heart to have a kid like Mario I
imagine you've got to be so supportive
and so loved
and you know have this kind of a you
know love just a really immense love
avail available to you so yeah I think
about the heart and I think about
resonating from the heart with me Rio
ironically like when I think of it to go
back to the question of like how I
strayed from the voice at all I do kind
of try to like throw it just a little
bit higher because he's always like at
the edge I feel like his Energy's very
bright and which is funny because they
even talked about that in the manga I
think what is it you know you're
brighter them or you're like the Sun
yeah
Tamaki says like man you're as bright as
the Sun and he's like bro you're way
better than me
good friends good friends but yeah sorry
to be verbose but your question yeah
that Wilson man that's a she funny you
say that cuz I remember the first time I
heard your voice in uh did you remember
the episode unrivaled like the very
first one yes yes because I had never
read the manga when I watched the
episode so I didn't know who this
character was and so like hearing the
energy it was just it was incredible to
be honest thanks man
yeah I you know you gotta trust your
director especially in shows I mean in
general but I mean Colleen's been doing
this kind of work for so long and she
assistant a good understanding of these
kinds of stories that you know I trust
her implicitly so when you know I'm I'm
like I think it's this guy man he
totally just did like this Bruce Lee
breathing moment I'm like I have a
feeling I know who this kid is like
after everything you don't really like
the kid that was doing the uh have you
seen that that video the little kid in
the Bruce Lee suit in the in the yellow
track suit doing the nunchucks perfectly
to the he's like copying it no fear did
I'm sure maybe I'll send it to you
anyway but it's it's you know Mario's
the kid that was probably trying to do
like he's playing Street Fighter and
then he tried to do Hadouken because he
was like if I focus hard enough you know
really I can do a you know Kamehameha I
really focus my power
I guarantee me Rio as a kid was trying
to do all of that oh for sure man I
definitely was but yeah yeah so the next
question what is this from okay so this
is from dads and it says what what was
it like to voice such an emotional
action-packed
and how many retakes did it take to
perfect that scene I think he's probably
referring to a minion episode you know
what's funny man we moved through that
episode pretty quick
but I guess that's the plus side of
having like a really strong directing
and engineering team Austin I was
engineering Austin Sisk and Colleen
Clinkenbeard was directing
I don't pat myself on the back but I
felt very confident coming in you know
I'd done my research as well and when we
just hand we were like I felt like we
were just hammering through the episode
like we did you know usually it was
First Take kind of stuff but then you
know Colleen's very specific about
whittling down these scenes so it's like
you know all right I see we head with
that let's try this let's try that all
right cool and then we kind of paint the
picture of where we want it to be and
then you know maybe take a whole nother
swing at it because I mean like my
tendency for instance there was a
there's one moment specifically and I
imagine if you're listening to this
you've seen the episode so apologies if
you haven't but there is a sequence
where miryo recognizes that area is
about to get disassembled and he sees
her like brace in the way that a person
who's used to getting hurt braces and
when he recognizes that he was a man
you've just been in pain your whole life
haven't you I did a version of that
where I played it very intimate as if I
was talking to you know a kid you know
an abused child and it was very
emotional and it felt it felt right it
felt so good and you know we're all kind
of weepy recording this moment and
Colleen had to tell me she's like you
know that's beautiful and it's awesome
but we we can't do that like we can't we
can't let it go low right here we have
to drive it we have to have this energy
for LA million because like even though
it's like you know we all agree that
this is a sweet moment and this is a
message that needs to be it's like you
we are also a middle of a fight you know
we have to preserve that energy and so
my actor temptation so like sometimes
get a little emotional and you know
maybe even sometimes reaching it to
melodrama like Colleen is there to rein
me in so I would say for the most part
we were we were you know hitting the
anvil and it was ringing out and
you know one two maybe three but that's
that's really all it took we yeah I
think felt very confident about what we
were doing
and do you guys like alternate between
the lines like when you're doing
different takes you I changed the line
oh yeah on the fly I mean sometimes it
depends on the adaptation of like you
know how much TLC was given to a certain
scene and oftentimes I find in very
dramatic moments you know that the
translation can get a little like just
the stresses on certain words sometimes
don't light up the same way I'm
struggling to look for an example right
now but it could be something as simple
as you know like the translation says
you know you I want to protect this girl
and I'm gonna be I'm going to be her
Savior yeah so we would translate that
to you know I'm I'll be the one to save
this girl right but I'm I'm gonna be her
hero it's like well this girl why are we
saying this girl in Japanese it makes
sense you know to say that because they
had they had laddered it a certain way
like their flow makes sense so we have
to I'm just gonna say Airy
you know or use this name what is the
potency of saying her name at this
moment mean did we say earlier and you
know what is our kind of flow in the in
the English it's honestly man sometimes
it's just like a trip of the tunnel like
there's different words that just sound
better together and match the animation
better so like I don't know I feel like
Colleen's again very adept at being able
to see the things that oh the biggest
one that she changed was a what is it
I'm not powerless cuz that was not
written in yeah no I'll show you an
Instagram talking about that line yeah
yeah man that one was a that one was
like we were approaching the end of
episode and you know it's Mira has been
been hit with a bullet and he's you know
struggling to fight but it's the mark of
someone who you know has gone through a
lot of struggle himself and has smacked
his face into the wall a bajillion times
and has risked his life to get good and
there's something to a person like that
that even when they you know
you can take away all their toys you can
take away all their money take away all
their clothes take but they're still
there you know what I mean although
everything they've built up is still
there and that is that's if that's a
force that's something I think you know
that uh that you know he he has always
known but to hear it articulated in that
you know really I'm not powerless like
that that it's like you know I think
it's a very assertive thing to say but I
can't remember with it with the Japanese
what we had in the translation it was
something like um
I will it won't be for nothing or it
won't be I won't be useless or something
like that it's like well why would we
let's the Colleen was like we she's not
about it for half a second was like I'm
not powerless I was like oh and the
second which she's wrote it she was
typing it out and I started getting
tears in my eyes and like that's that's
what this guy's about yeah you know what
I mean yeah I know you mean when in fact
for the Japanese version oh I don't know
if you saw the the subbed version of the
latest episode but I remember overall
kept on saying this one line it was like
it was all for nothing it was all for
nothing he kept on saying that over and
over I guess yes see I guess what you
said was kind of what you were gonna say
would be the inverse of that I guess
yeah yeah and I mean it's it's it's
delicate balance man because you know we
always want clarity the story always
comes first
we're always trying to make sure that
everyone is getting the story but you
know in some of these moments it's like
well the language isn't isn't helping us
out right now like how do we how do we
support the narrative you know and then
also then it's like almost after the
fact like now I have to render it as
natural as possible as the actor and and
still give it that that heart that it
needs you know which I would say
sometimes is like the easiest part but I
got it cuz because when it comes to
writing man like I would probably it
would be like session halting error I
would just sit there and probably be
agonizing over a line or all right guys
break everyone take a break Rico's got a
rewrite one line I'm powerless for hours
later so yeah okay well just before we
move on to the next question because
something you said it kind of like just
made me think when you guys are
recording do you have like the
animations playing there to see how your
voice like syncs up with it or not
oh sure yes we definitely have the
animation it's pretty rare that we do
not I mean every once in a while like it
might not be the final animation some
sometimes they call it because like you
know the the production houses might
still be working on a fight scene to
make something a little fancier or you
know maybe they might have had an error
of some kind like I've caught some
animations sometimes that have like a
character that had like a cape or
something and then they didn't animate
it in and so there's like a teleporting
cape you're like oh my god that's like
huge that's bad so you know sometimes
while they're changing that they might
change the the what we call the flaps as
well which is the the mouth movements
that we're supposed to match yeah so
yeah typically we have the animation I
think some I can speak on part of most
of my acting friends that our favorite
kind of animation is pre lay meaning you
they give you the line you say it
however you please and they animate to
your voice that's probably some of the
most exciting voice voice-over work you
can do because you just have so much
Liberty but you know everything has its
charm it's also very fun to to have some
some constraints like you know searing
seeing me Rio say you know I am la
million and he's like the musculature of
his mouth it's like oh man in that
specific scene you can see that he's
literally saying you know love million
like it's it's difficult to not script
that that he did you know that way but
I'm just take you out of a little yeah
sorry I kind of got yeah yeah really I
mean it would it would like but to speak
to not having the animation sometimes we
do have you know I think back in the day
before they would have animation
sometimes they would have like they've
have to guess at it they'd have like
little little bits of like keyframes of
scenes
I know sometimes whenever I've worked on
video games they would be like yet we
don't have the animation for the video
games but we have like these three sort
of stills and we kind of need to match
this sort of cadence of this foreign
language if I'm dubbing but yeah so it
you know yeah you get it in a variety of
packages yeah
listen man okay let's move on to the
next question so this one's from Beast
Boy and you kind of already answered
half of this question but he says do you
read the manga and if you do what's your
favorite theory right now oh yeah so
definitely rather read the read the
manga favorite theory right now well you
know I was hanging out with my friend in
LA of the day Felicia in jail she plays
Toto hagakure she's invisible girl and
she's all my close friends and we were
chatting and I was doing a signing from
a little Mario pop figure and she she
and I were just chatting in the in the
idle moments and I was like dude so I
don't really know much about this whole
like there's a spy somewhere on the
heroes side but like it's you right it's
gotta be you you're like you're
invisible or maybe like this because I
don't know there's always just something
about she's always around and she's just
got gloves they've no idea what she
looks like
maybe that's there's some metaphor there
for like fear of the unknown but I'm
like you're the spy arch well you know
you make a good point because like there
might be some time she's even then you
wouldn't know because she's not wearing
gloves or whatever else so yes that's
right and so someone someone approached
me and said like maybe like do you think
maybe Maria was the spy and I was like I
would have my heart broken in like 9,000
pieces if that was what you'd ever do
you know I'd be like I don't know I
don't know you know I've been I've been
hurt before man yeah but I don't think
that's the case I would I would not like
that I would not like that to us at all
yeah me neither
I would I'd have to go for like a long
soul-searching journey into the into the
mountains so what do you think of the
idea of every potentially giving me Rio
is quite back in the future you know
obviously it's it's it's something that
seems to be in the cards they're very
close you know
Arian me Rio for those who've read ahead
they're you know two peas in a pod like
to think he's like you know in my in my
future I don't know if all I will ever
adopt a kid and I hopefully have the
have the this the spirit and I guess
hopefully the funds to do to be able to
do that and pass on good stuff to a you
know take care of another human that way
but essentially me Rio does that and I
I've witnessed I know he's witnessed
arey you know go through a bunch of pain
and seeing as how her quirk is one that
does not really bring her pleasure
necessarily and can endanger her life I
don't think Miriah is really on the side
of arey using it much at all
to do anything even though it seems to
be like a temporal thing like she can
kind of keep someone in stasis but like
also revert them to a to a previous
literally revert someone to a previous
yeah I don't know if it's like a time
ability if it's like you know Prince of
Persia sands of time
what debates about Ares quick like it's
not even funny right doesn't yeah so and
I know she's sorry good oh I'm just
gonna say like there's not a lot known
about it even even now like fully
up-to-date in the manga we still don't
know enough about it right oh well I
guess I could theorize about that I
would say that you know I was just
saying this the other night that I think
Airy because she's so cute and small but
so ope like with her ability that I feel
like it's a time a time thing sort of
and that she can advance or you know
reverse time on someone which by the way
like okay reverse all my back to his
prime and we've got a whole whole page
again you know anything work with wild
we got you know but you know obviously
it comes with risks she could go too far
she could go you know and then her horn
it seems to be connected to that so I
theorized that there might become a time
where era uses her ability and maybe
there's some kind of equivalent exchange
here we're like it advances her age so
she's gonna like age quicker and then
like she's gonna get these kind of cool
like succubus horns that pop out and
she'll you know she's still gonna be
sweet Airy but just grown up which will
be weird because then it's like wait are
you still tiny cuz I'm gonna treat you
like a kid forever don't grow up they
grow fast literally so that's kind of my
my two cent like just off-the-cuff
theory like you just came up did you
come up with that just now last night I
was just kind of noodling around I was
like you know I I based on her because
she's like she is definitely like a one
of the the set pieces on the board that
are like story wise that it's hard to
reconcile right now because yes we
understand we can't really use her power
right now I'm sure they're training or
someone's
training and what better person to have
trained you then Muriel who's like why
don't you just fail a bunch yeah you can
do that because if she messes up she
might like kill someone then you know
who that early and that is not what you
know we want any any I don't think
anyone wants area to go through but yeah
I think that's a that's my that is my
theory is that Ares kind of like tied
somehow to like some sort of chrono you
know temporal sort of thing and that's
how she's able to keep you know deku in
infinite infinite uh full cowling you
know and just complete kick kicking ass
yeah yeah I agree I think it's to do
with time as well but I think a few
people think is to do more like the
cellular level yeah right
because without overall like rebuild her
you know what I mean like I think that
now we get to see what cuz she never had
the opportunity to mature past that
state overall kept bringing her back to
that state yeah I think you know any man
and she never I'm when she was with
overall like she never really used it
like she was being experimented on but
she never really used the quote for any
reason right right
I think maybe and that's the reason why
overhaul hadn't even really done full
research he was like all I know is that
she can make someone's court go away
forever that's what he goes which
essentially is like yeah the clerk takes
time to manifest so maybe he what
they're doing on a cellular levels is
bringing them to like you know pre quick
mode which in then what happens a vase
get a bit older when they just get their
quark back again so sly man 64 rights
what was it like working with legends
like Christopher sabar who plays out all
my oh yeah I reckon texting Chris Abbott
this morning I was like I'm trying to do
a really fun panel over at my hero con
I'm trying to do like a live dubbing
panel so I needed some advice from him
but yeah it's great it's always a little
weird I feel though because I've gotten
to this point I love acting and I've
studied acting for a very long time but
I've also you know listened to dragon
ball since I'm a kid so to like so work
with Chris it's I don't know it's time
it's a
sort of like a it's work right so like
I'm still focused I'm still doing my job
and I'm like delighted like from an
actor point of view not even thinking
about like the the legendary status as
you said because like you know you work
with some really talented people and you
kind of just like at least for me when
I'm working with these folks these kinds
of folks who have done so much it's like
I am so excited yeah I'm so I'm so happy
to be playing with someone who's so so
talented and so playful and like cuz
inherent like Chris is so playful and
he's got such a wonderful instrument and
he's like very charismatic it's like I'm
delighted I'm just I'm like a kid in a
candy store when I get to play cost
someone like that you know I mean and
Justin Breiner oh my god I worked with
him for so many years now and so many
different projects and it's like I'm
delighted I'm just I'm always tickled
but when I take a step back I guess I've
never really been like like the fanboy
type but when I when I like sit inside
of the the couch the baby me the the
couch of my mind where I was watching
Dragonball mall holy cow man this is
really cool I feel I feel very humbled
and honored to be like woven into
narratives with people who I have also
had the pleasure to be affected by their
storytelling as well you know I'm
literally yeah it's like I'm I'm not so
much to say like I was you know forever
changed by things like Dragon Ball but I
gotta tell you man like it's to this day
I still carry you know you know Yamcha
and a crater you know we all carry these
these things these distinct images and I
know that I know it was my with my hero
like sorry just sorry it's a it was just
that you mention yeah I'm sure he does
he play Yamcha as well I believe so yeah
yeah that's right so anyway yeah I know
everyone's probably like ah Vegeta this
Vegeta that I'm like bro yeah I'm she's
a human yeah like it's so much harder
than he's a human and he's fighting a
like Opie aliens like you guys gotta
remember scaling is important here yeah
like anyway Krillin god come on you guys
strong as hell anyway um but yes I gotta
say it is an honor it's very humbling
at like my absolute you know nerdiest I
just I was just so happy to be working
with like really skilled fun people it's
just there's nothing there's nothing
more fun like I am in a name drop here
just for a moment just cuz I my
girlfriend was in Hamilton hope and
raining she she worked on the Broadway
so Katrina yeah she she worked on
Hamilton and I got to meet Lynn mmmm
lin-manuel Miranda at the LA opening of
Hamilton and so I was hanging out with
him and I was like hey Lynn do you
remember me cuz back in 2011 way back
the way way back when he was writing
that show I got to beatbox with him on
stage I be boxed for him and he
freestyled and I remember thinking man
this guy is so freaking talented he's so
well-read like when you have this this
theory that you one of the best ways to
get to know actors and is is to improv
with them oh yeah because usually they
leave with their strengths yeah always
it's like they always leave with their
strengths so like you know if they're if
they're super attractive they can just
sit back and smile and everyone like you
know fawns over them if they're you know
really good uh you know inventors you
know or are like character people I'm
thinking of oh gosh
there's so many there's so many there's
so many um oh my goodness why can't
reverse me right now the actor he's in
Barry he was on SNL does a ton of great
sketches oh my god hater Bill Hader oh
yeah Bill Hader is a wonderful character
guy yeah he's just he's so so good but
when it comes to like listening to good
writers like writing is also an acting
ability Lynn ma'am lin-manuel miranda is
one of the finest like writers that I've
ever like got to improv with because you
can just hear the words that he comes up
with and the things that pop that spill
out of him you're like oh the first
thing I thought was this guy is so
well-read he's read so many books I can
just tell based on the the thoughts and
the way that he orchestrates the the
words coming out of his mind like yes he
has a lot of books just stored up in
there so sorry I was a little tan
gential there but uh coming back to
working with with like very very you
know legendary voice folks it's yeah
she i Mike mcFarland you know Kaitlyn
glass all these people it's it's it's
still a trip to be able to like sit with
them and just be like yeah we're you
know we're homeboys and we're making
some art a talented bunch that is for
sure so moving on I have a question from
Asuka midoriya not the real one and he
is and he says when voicing myrio is
positive and happy attitude does this
affect you and like make you a more
positive person I think we're like on
par I guess you know like there is every
once in a while
like I'll catch myself there's this
weird thing and I almost did it for
Mario's dad that he was like it's like
kind of a light sort of like aha
like like did you get the joke that it's
a little open mouth sound that goes like
huh it's one of the first things he
doesn't goes trash am i right
there's a little aha sound like that he
just makes and I was gonna have Mario's
dad do it and go like huh and like kind
of blood it'd be it from the other thing
I didn't end up doing it but um but I
find myself I catch myself doing that
sometimes but I just like like I like
throw it out and I'm like oh my god is
it so um I'll say to to that and a
little bit of me Rio has been kind of
working its way to my life and for good
reason recently um yeah I think we
already shared that kind of sort of
optimism and just just happiness to be
around you know grateful to be to be
here I had to talk about fan theories
before about you know I think there's a
thing popping around online where the
big three are like emblematic of the
things that like 3 the biggest
challenges we face in high school which
is like Hado is has like a TD she's like
constantly looking around and she hurt
you know if she has a hard time focusing
on one thing
i'ma Jiki is like an introversion but
like you know tentative kind of social
I'm very very nervous a you know quieter
keeping themselves sort of like I can't
think of the right terminology for that
the moment but for for me Rio like
actually depression because even though
he's a bright shiny person like he has
to delve into this dark dark dark place
or he's alone can't hear anything he's
you know like he and I don't know about
you but some of the most like bright
shiny people that I know are also
sometimes the most oppressive yeah and
there's this duality there right where
it's like how does someone stay so happy
all the time how does someone say so
optimistic it's usually because they
recognize the dark they can they know
how crummy it is to be sad they know how
so it's like why even waste time doing
that when I could be up here like just
enjoying my life with these people you
know so I think even his quirk is sort
of emblematic of that that you know
falling into the earth where you are
alone and if one little slip and you
could lose your life yeah you know what
I mean and his dad says that it's like
which and in effect I mean that's like
you could call it suicide you could call
it you know like because it is you
you're in control of it do you want to
do this are you risking are you willing
to take the risk to to be a hero you
know fortunately he says yes and things
turn out as we've been seeing the show
but I can imagine them you know a not
happy person if we were watching a
darker anime but uh but yeah man I I do
think that the positivity is something
that you know for both Mira and myself
there are the ebbs and flows ups and
downs of life but sort of generally just
being happy that you know you you were
able to to get up and work on something
like having I think it's also lit
related to his quirk because everyone
told him it was garbage
you know his it was like not good but he
had a goal you know determination you
know his father supported him you know
he came to me tonight I who supported
him he had a good group of people he had
some good friends who supported him you
know he didn't do it alone
he and through that he was able to
really I think groom this perspective on
life this positivity so yeah I think I
also am surrounded by even though I
don't look around very often but I I do
have some really some kick-ass people in
my life and yeah and your cell phone
talking right now because I can clearly
clearly share energy so it's like you
know I think that's why miryo resonates
with a lot of people I love personally
for me Emilio is my favorite character
but it's interesting what you say about
his quark actually because like he is
literally just like he can't see
think on here anything is just complete
darkness and yet he is the most bright
and positive person like when he's
talking to people it is it I've never
thought about it in that way before but
isn't interesting yep his clothes fall
off he's literally naked like I mean I
know it's kind of a joke for people but
it's like have you ever been naked in
front of a crowd of people like it's
there's nothing more liberating and both
embarrassed huh I've done theater we did
some naked scene sometimes but like it's
a it's a thing man like you literally
you literally are revealing yourself I
mean I think that's what Mario's about
he's just unapologetically him himself
you know and you know there are people
that love them they're people that you
know don't or maybe maybe he does like a
lemon which by the way what's once
overall you know once the bullet
connected I was like oh you guys can be
friends now right because he's not sick
anymore but then Mayer starts throwing
them hands you know I love them in the
in the dub I loved when uh kelan was
kind of just like going off about run
after me Rico he was like this whole
rant about how ironic it wasn't even got
shot and blah blah blah I actually love
that part
oh dude is great so strong I'm so proud
of kelan and actually I know there are
some folks that were talking about the
animation because like I was a little a
little thrown when they started doing
like the still frames toward the end
there you know out of them fully animate
it but it does allow more for
imagination and honestly some of those
hits like where he punches overhauls for
arm that'll actually that's like a hit
that will make her forum go numb which
means that he can't use he can't use his
hands as much which is I was like oh me
oh so smart anyway no I'm the thing is
the thing about this stills was that
that wasn't actually in the manga
originally so I'm like on one hand I'm
like okay they've done something new and
they've added something so I don't know
I did kind of take me out of it a little
bit but then I was thinking it wasn't in
the manga so they kind of just added
this on for us so I guess I don't know
right yeah the well the music like yeah
exactly because we don't see it in the
it's like all we knows myrio has been
fighting for I think four or five
minutes he's just been going by himself
without a Kirk which is like I mean you
know around and boxing is like a
fraction of that it's like I can't
imagine that doing well you know like
especially against overall like I think
that's what it was yeah is it's like
showing these little pictures showing
like one vignette like you know to give
you an idea of what's occurring and
every Posey hits is like so heroic and
so you know iconic inside of those
little frames because I yeah I will
admit for me I was like a little taken
out of it at first but then I'm a pretty
big music guy so the second I heard the
music has supported it I was like I see
what you're you're allowing us to really
just drink in like it's like our own
fights
it's the struggles where we feel
powerless like I wanna I want a weap
right now even just saying it like it's
those moments dude that we hit all the
time where it's like you know you you
know you lose a loved one you have a big
breakup you lost your job all this stuff
it's like but I'm still here and I'm
still fighting like so moving on to
another question so this one's from
Ghent oh and they said as a more
personal question out of all the
characters you voice - what is your
favorite I'm all I care - the voice what
is my favorite it's it's hard to Maria
is just always right here right now I
one that always holds a special place in
my heart
there's it's not quite a tie I would say
civil silver metal metal the silver
medal will go to lay on Luis in oh god
oh I was the lead in that show he's the
golden Knight he struggled a lot with
the idea of avenge and family a lot a
lot of issues with that and just kind of
being it might seem like he's just kind
of a XD edge Lord emo kid but you know
he's got a lot of a lot of anger and
hate inside and wants to communicate it
to the world I think that's I don't know
I feel like a lot of people feel that at
some point in their lives and he there's
a scene I got to play there's a turning
point for for Leone where he meets a
girl and played by brina palencia who's
the person actually that ever for the
first
got me a an audition or a Funimation we
read met on a film set our good friends
been friends for a long time but she I
got to play a scene across from her and
she was a just a farm farm girl you know
and my character ironically has lost his
powers at this point in this show I
guess that's not a thing for me like
yeah I didn't anyway I just recognize
that now anybody's talking with her it's
a very dramatic scene in it man i it's
those times where you feel really really
connected to something cuz it kind of
reached out from the anime and into life
a bit and so that being said the gold
medal I will say despite a miryo side I
kinda have to give miryo free pass miss
and just sit let him sail because it's
two it's two in front of my face right
now I would say it's a hero from grim
garb ashes and illusions or grimgar
fantasy ash that's one of the first kind
of I guess no well is is a lead role
he's a thief in this sort of you know
fictitious world of grimgar it's very
mysterious about where they're from but
and and you know how they're gonna help
each other but there's real stakes like
the opening episode is them trying to
kill one goblin and they can't bring
themselves to do it because first off
they don't really know how to fight and
number two it's really hard to take the
life of a living thing yes it should be
and I think you know they they're trying
to struggle with it but they all have
these their own perspective on it you
know his buddy Ron says trying to prove
himself and just wants to be a badass
you know one of the girls is struggling
with like like weight issues they all
like these little subtle storyline
things but what's cool about it all I
think is that I hadn't really met any of
the actors involved so mono - and that
in that show is played by Justin Bryan
who's you know deku in my hero and he's
my close friend in that show he's
actually like I look up to him he's
amazing he's awesome and he ends up
making a wonderful sacrifice to save us
all and it's like these mutton I still
communicate to him because of course
it's a you know it's a kind of RPG land
kind of sword art online kind of world
so I'm able to commune with this spirit
and
these lovely moments where I felt like I
learned so much about Justin Briner
Jeannie tirado surveyed inept they're
all my little party we had on a little
group Jared green both Orion pits and
and cliff shape and when he did the
voice match there's a all of all of them
I felt so close to because I would
narrate just constantly about them and
our relationships and was all kind of
slice of life in the way that that
dialogue happened so it just felt so
simple and honest and real and yeah I
really enjoy that
I enjoyed that aspect of it and of
course I'm a big RPG nerd and I always
play a thief whenever I can and my
character was a thief he was a rogue and
I'm like oh my god it's perfect it was
great and I think Jamie Markey was my it
was my trainer
she was my like rogue teachers like of
course very sexy you know thief teacher
showed me how to do back flips and stuff
and stabbed people
but um yeah did that show really really
I think captured my heart and I sit
stays with me to stay just because
beautiful watercolor amazing music and
the people the people men having your
little crew adventuring into the unknown
and learning about them is just I think
one of my favorite things my favorite
game is Chrono Trigger
it's an old SNES game it's like similar
you meet these characters and you learn
so much about them you know anyway okay
everyone listening who heard that just
now you heard him say that he's never
heard of Chrono Trigger and I just want
to get this we're recording this we have
it officially I my head is exploding
right now in Dallas I will get you I
will get you a copy of it do you have a
DNS I mean I do have one yeah I haven't
used it for a while yeah okay okay I'll
get you on we listen we can I'll find
you a copy self out anyway I hope you
play this game and let occupy your idle
time so it's really amazing that's right
yes yes yes so it's about 15 minutes now
so we got do have time for two more
questions is that okay sure sure
yeah please keep we can keep we can keep
pushing I uh I can you know I got
I'm looking at my clock and I'm trying
to text my buddy so I he's not waiting
for me yeah we're good okay cool so this
next questions from Gabrielle and they
said what was your initial reaction
after hearing that Mario would lose his
quark and or did you already know of
this episode months before it was time
to record it oh yeah I knew about this a
while ago so when I told you the earlier
Afra mentioned story of me going and
grabbing the manga at the store I was
outside of a Kinokuniya little bookstore
out here in Carrollton Texas and I had a
little like latte I gotten from a bakery
pretty close by and I cracked open the
manga with my character on the front of
it I'm like how exciting let me lean
this is great and I'm reading it and I
see that hee hee the big smiley picture
where he gets hit by the bullet and I
openly wept like a child in this in this
cafe I was just sitting there I was like
again unapologetically like no like this
is this is so noble and it's so far away
and it's so like I don't know it's
everything you you would want and expect
and a character like this and I was I
can't believe I want to get to play him
I can't like so there's a mixture of
like joy but also just like sadness but
also like this is I mean it's like
hero's death you don't even give me a
hero's death put me in there you know he
was in the right place at the right time
a lot of people come up to me at
conventions be like are you sad isn't it
sad and I'm like nah man it's exactly
how it's supposed to be like cuz I don't
think everyone understands there's a
really beautiful shot also the more
important shot other than Emilia smiling
is the the picture of Airy
kind of ensorcelled or swaddled in that
in Miri escape yeah and when when when
Deku reaches for her hand it's there's a
shot of her holding the cape going you
know well if he can sacrifice something
and he can take risk and he can do this
for me I can also take a risk associates
the my hero seems to have this running
theme of you know passing on energy
passing on quirks passing on you know
energy really and I guess in in this
case for me Ryo with his sacrifice he
pet he gave literally gave arey a shot
he made her
for us for a moment and that's all that
they needed instead of her going back to
overhaul and essentially sealing the
deal she and you know is able to go to
deku because Muriel you know with again
it cost him everything but it's like
sometimes all you need is just just one
little slice of hope yeah and that's
actually a really good point because
like miryo literally sacrificed his
quark with like you say yeah this
massive smile in his face like he was
willing to do it cuz I had a few people
comment on one of my beliefs and videos
and they were saying oh why didn't me
Rio just you know push Sheri out of the
way or someone mystery said to me why
didn't my didn't maybe a dropkick
arrey Out Boy what do you thought I mean
okay I mean if we wanna weekend like
death battle this and talk about like
mathematically how it all could break
down but really I mean so take from what
I just said about you know seeing that a
person having a person go to bat for you
I just read an article actually it's
funny before we started recording I was
just kind of leafing through some some
online articles and one was talking
about how if you give your best to
someone yeah helping someone just out of
out of goodwill it asserts their value
it shows that they are worth it and I
think if you remember what overhauls
been saying to area this whole time is
you're worthless you're you hurt people
you are bad you are not a good thing for
someone to reach out to you and watch
them put everything on the line for you
you you are now bound to that you know
you you are now your your computer
complicit you're in this because this
person says no you are a value are worth
and I'm gonna show you by by by
literally bleeding for you by hurting
for you so to see someone do that for
you personally I think what sort of I
don't know those Mario's goal
necessarily you know I don't think you
know if you had it his way yeah let's
say there and get out of here but
remember how remember how the story was
set up
overall says listen I've got you trapped
I'm gonna hit Airy like I'm gonna
get her I'm gonna hurt her you can't
keep her safe forever
cuz you know literally overhaul is this
gonna fill it with spikes so Mario's
goal is to also protect her I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna let you get hurt
anymore so even though that is a little
bullheaded a little stubborn
you know like cuz yeah if he was
thinking outside of the box he's like
well you know maybe he's a little more
chaotic good maybe he could be like yeah
let's let's just let Airy get you know I
call your bluff
go ahead hurt her I'll just I'll just
permeate and maybe just like hold her
and let you like impale her and then go
ahead and put her back together cuz you
have to cuz you need her right or yeah
dropkick her out of the way which would
then also like you know save her and
then maintain Mario for a second but
remember he was engaged with overhaul he
was trying to knock overhaul out
so again Mario is pretty pretty badass
but he literally can't be in three
places at once so it was well it was
well it was well played by the the the
she has I Chi and it was also well
played I think by Mary I think it was
honestly his best shot because he's also
if you remember the last thing he says
during the episode he's like guys I'm
still fighting like he knows his role
he's like I'm gonna sit here I'm gonna
tank and I'm just gonna I'm gonna fight
for as long as I can until I know my
friends are coming so yeah don't drop
kick arrey more all the story like don't
hurt the kid that's being used to
getting hurt so what have we got here
okay so this one's actually really good
question so this one's from fill the
logician and he says do you have any
tips for upcoming voice actors any any
tips for upcoming voice actors oh so
many so I went to school for a long time
for acting did my undergrad at Alma Bali
College um California UC Irvine
California got my bachelor's there and
then did my masters studying classical
theater at Southern Methodist University
they brought me out in Dallas I have a
pretty extensive like a bit of an
academic I scholastic scholastically
addicted to acting in theatre I love it
I love the study of it so that's almost
a disclaimer because what I'm gonna say
is probably really
pedantic and I do teach you know I every
once a while go up to a spring rain
spring green Wisconsin and American
players theater and I'll teach like for
a week there some of their talented kids
and I used to teach like at Richland
College and at SMU
but what usually comes down to is ain't
nothing to it but to do it start start
acting and it's it's it's it's I gotta
say it sounds so simple but the key is
to practice it learn the learn the art
form Eric Vale always like will bludgeon
me what this is why we him and I laugh
about it but it's like you know do
theater go out and do a play if that
makes you feel weird like you know
because you like well I don't want to do
theater I want to do voice acting I'm
like do theater because there is more to
it than simply making cool sounds into a
microphone that's one component yes and
I've seen God so many so many talented
people behind the mic way more talented
than me never be able to book a job or
make a career because there are other
fundamentals they aren't aware of
contrary to what I guess Naruto you know
knowledge about like talent what is it
you know talents not everything I think
of rock Lee a bit when I think you know
like it's a it's a it's a there you you
can be very skilled you can be very
talented but without the hard work it is
it is meaningless you need to be able to
go and and hone it down and also the
other way contrast Lee if you don't have
much talent hard work will make up for
that you can you can kind of you can
start to discover talents as you try to
do more things because all you're aware
of right now that's so much of what
theatre is is discovering who you are
and what you're like capable of
communicating it's a communication art
you know you learn about your voice in
all its different ways you learned about
your body which is linked to your voice
in many different ways
you learn about archetypes you learn
about all the different stories that
have been told because that's
essentially what we're doing we're doing
storytelling you should you should watch
The Witcher you know you should pay
close attention to the way the camera
moves you should listen to the music you
should listen to the dialect that Geralt
has to do because he's trying to match
that beautiful voice that Geralt of
Rivia has and hairy camels like or Henry
camels like yeah this is a very this is
a very deep voice it's like that is a
hard voice to pull off dude while also
doing stage combat you know what I mean
anyway there is a lot and I I will say
that is what makes acting so much fun is
that there is so much you can learn so
much you can do but it I suggest playing
going out there and playing and doing
theater and obviously it's subjective
because I mean there's some people out
there who've been doing theater and they
might say you know well but well I've
been doing theater and I want to you
know I want to learn more about voice
acting specifically you know because now
I know how you know how to like shoot my
voice across the stage but how to do it
with a mic and like great keep doing
like you know there's more roads that
kind of splinter off from that and it's
like okay great we'll have you I would
do musical theater next because now
you're singing and that's how you
properly learn how to care for your
voice you also learn what your vocal
range it is you know what music is right
for you quote-unquote right for you
because you know I'm probably not gonna
start singing some beautiful soprano
song right away because I know it's out
of my range but I might give it a shot
with enough practice I would like you
know it's a me video no but yeah I think
it's everyone's journey is is unique and
I will say though that the something
that will apply to everyone and it
applies to me I still take classes you
know I would leap at the chance to to be
able to do a play but right now I am
entrenched in some anime so but you know
when I get the opportunity I'll probably
do a play because I will leave you with
this this little final adage it's a
because I do a lot of commercial work I
also do on camera stuff it's a poem
commercials
make your rich film makes you famous
but theater theater makes you good and
so there's a balance between those three
that you need to you need to understand
so if you're doing voice acting and
you've got to ask yourself why I want to
be in a big cool
oh you must want to be famous and that's
not a bad thing you know it might be a
little linked here you go but it might
also be linked to your pocketbook who
knows if you want to be you know rich
then why are you even doing anime you
don't get paid Welding anime like get
out of here go do a commercial for you
know cook a coal or something make all
that money like you know again you still
have to study to do it but like that's
but if you want to be good if you want
to be good at acting and good at what
you do and learn and understand it got
to do theater so that is that's the best
I guess I can I can give to as a general
sort of acting tip and I'm sorry if it
sounds redundant but I can definitely I
am on the Twitter so if you tweet at me
I will usually try to DM me I can try to
give you some some little bits of advice
if I'm if I'm able to but specificity
please be specific with your question
yes specificity is also the key oh
that's awesome well thank you so much
for coming on the channel today honestly
for me this has been kind of surreal
because like I say what like around July
last year like I heard your voice and I
can't believe I'm actually speaking to
you now it's pretty crazy but yeah it's
a trip but isn't life crazy I would love
to I would love to do this again I got
some point in the future if that's cool
with you sure yeah man I mean as long as
I'm able to it's you know if I can I'll
do it
it's just you know as a matter of
scheduling and I think after Mario gets
to take a little bit of a break yeah so
I'll probably be more available
depending on casting and stuff like that
but I'm doing a bunch of conventions in
2020s you'll see me all over the world
where are you at anyway I'm in London
right now are you coming to London oh
well yeah I can't say cuz it's not
announced but yeah so we'll probably
meet up pull me yeah I'll let you in
London ah yeah me yeah
my crap did I just throw in the podcast
I'm sorry
you got it yeah okay do you have
anything like you want to shout out like
any convention you're doing very soon oh
yeah
so what wouldn't I don't know what in
this podcast is gonna pop up but I'm
doing my hero con in Arlington Texas
smash in just a few weeks also even
sooner than that if you're in San
Antonio on my friend Brittany Lauda and
and Matt Shipman and I will be willing
to pack south which is a gaming
convention one of our favorites somebody
out there playing games and maybe
sentence monographs talking about
voiceover as well there so those are the
two for January I believe I might have
another one coming up that it's been
announced oh I think galaxy con
announced me for November of 2020 and
like I believe it's a yeah that's it's a
little far out so that's a ways but they
did announce me so I can talk about that
but in any case yeah there I'll post
about it but yeah just follow me on
Twitter it's Rico Fajardo it's who sees
and yeah again if you have any questions
about like acting stuff feel free to D
on me I do my best to get back to you is
when I can although I've been kind of
swamped with all the love for me Rio
recently so I will I'll get to you in my
best of time what's the matter well
thank you so much
Rico for everyone thanks guys take it
easy and remember go beyond plus ultra
you